he's my friend
so was i
[Music]
hey guys i'm philip molina and oh my god
that trailer and that footage and i've
been waiting for this for so long and
yes looking at it it looks amazing but
also it's like why are mommy and daddy
fighting is it something i did like
don't you feel terrible seeing the end
and they hate each other and like in the
comics it was really easy to pick a side
between cap and iron man because in the
comics tony stark is a douche during
civil war but here with these actual
people on screen and i like them both so
much i'm just totally torn so to
completely distract myself from picking
aside i'm going to ignore that angst of
superhero divorce and instead i'm going
to break down this trailer i'm going to
try to point out anything that i can
analyze some moments some easter eggs
and maybe just highlight anything that
you might have missed if you consider
rumors and speculation to be spoilers
then yeah spoilers are on the way but
it's basically just gonna be a lot of me
guessing anyway uh let's get right into
it
buck
do you remember me
your mom's name was sarah right off the
bat we get a little bit more of that
scene that we initially saw as the
post-credits scene from ant-man i know a
guy and this is just adding on to that
and if you stitch the two scenes
together you realize that bucky's in a
lot of trouble cause some people are
hunting him thinking he did some
terrible thing that he claims he didn't
do but you know it's still in addition
to the terrible things that he did do
because if you remember as winter
soldier the guy was an assassin for
hydra and killed tons of people for
decades so you can kind of understand
why some people are thinking yeah maybe
he's not a good guy of course cap is
maybe the only person that still sees
him as a good guy and you can tell that
he's very forgiving about this guy
because when he asks bucky if he
remembers him bucky's response is
basically i remember your mama your
mom's name is sarah
that is a good friendship it's also
worth mentioning that in the ant-man
version of this scene cap is actually
suggesting that they call tony stark if
we call tony or he won't believe us so i
guess at least in this moment they don't
totally hate each other you're a wanted
man
as we move a little forward we've got
some chaos after a huge explosion and
did you notice what was getting blown up
like take a look at that shot again on
the podium there that looks a lot like
the un logo making this some sort of un
committee meeting now as we covered in
our what's not gonna be in civil war
video we know that this movie is not
gonna feature the huge inciting incident
from the comic books known as the
stanford incident where a freaking
elementary school gets wiped out by a
huge explosion but wiping out part of
the un assembly could also probably be a
major inciting incident too probably big
enough to cause some major friction and
also you gotta wonder if this is what
people think that bucky might have done
yeah it makes sense that they're hunting
him i don't do that anymore well the
people who think you did are coming
right now
they're not planning on taking you alive
moving on we get a glimpse of the team
that may or may not be the ones after
bucky but they're definitely storming
some sort of highly guarded compound
having taken out some security guards
already and if you're really eagle-eyed
you might have noticed who else is in
there with them right there x on his
chest that's crossbones aka brock rumlow
one of the villains of this movie and
we've actually met him before he was the
guy who turned out to be a hydra during
winter soldier and then he gets his
whole body like smushed and yet somehow
he still comes back and he's probably
deadlier than ever as bucky and cap
fight some dudes you can see that it
says pulitzei on their chest which is
german for police and the significance
of that well we actually don't see him
but the movie's big bad guy which yes i
know it's ridiculous there's another
huge villain in this movie we haven't
even seen he's baron zemo who is from
germany so logic would imply that
something about being in germany is
going to connect us to zemo then bucky
makes his big escape and we're into the
marvel logo and the only thing i want to
point out before we move on is how
surprisingly focused this trailer has
been on bucky we now know that's because
the russo brothers who are the guys
making this film they wanted to find a
way to tell the civil war story but not
make it just about two different
political ideologies that captain
america and iron man don't agree on
instead they wanted to make it a very
personal story for captain america and
now we can see it's clear this is not an
avengers movie this is the captain
america movie which is why instead
they're exploring themes of loyalty and
betrayal between not just a soldier and
his government but between groups of
friends that's good stuff captain
while a great many people see you as a
hero
there are some who'd prefer the word
vigilante
you've operated with unlimited power and
no supervision
that's something the world can no longer
tolerate
then we get our first glimpse of general
thaddeus thunderbolt ross who uh we
haven't seen in eight freaking years and
what's awesome about his appearance is
that it actually firmly connects now the
incredible hulk movie to the marvel
cinematic universe they weren't totally
actually connected before it's also
great to see him because william hurt
isn't just great in this role his
character if he keeps showing up will
eventually turn into red hulk and that's
amazing that'd be great also rumor has
it that thunderbolt ross is more of a
secretary of state type these days which
is a position that deals much more with
our country's relationships around the
globe that's significant because in the
comics the superhero registration act is
something local to the united states and
characters could just escape it by going
to canada or france but this story is
taking things much more global we saw
that a second ago with the german police
and then we're seeing that again here
where bucky disappears in either a
spanish or italian speaking country and
finally we see it with the sokovia
accords themselves that's a un logo
which means these accords are basically
global law also different from the
comics in them the act is more about
superheroes revealing their secret
identities to the us government but here
with the set of accords it seems like
it's more about taking away superhero
independence it's the u.n that cares and
not just the us government now because
sokovia if you remember is the eastern
european country that ultron tried to
slam dunk back into the earth recently
and that destruction combined with what
happened in new york in avengers 1 and
basically the stuff that's happened in
every third act of every marvel movie
and everything we've seen so far it all
means that the disasters have affected
the entire planet the cover says it's a
framework for the registration and
deployment of enhanced individuals and
if you remember enhanced is the word
agents of shield used to use for super
powered people before they started being
all about inhumans and ross is
explaining that all superheroes need to
be operating under the oversight of the
ua you've operated with unlimited power
and no supervision that's something the
world can no longer tolerate and while
he means everybody he mostly is talking
about the avengers himself in the marvel
phase 2 blu-ray box set you get to see a
page of the accords that could maybe
just be marketing but it has this
section for the avengers themselves
although it also calls them los
vengadores but it's about them signing
away their ability to operate
independently they'll now have to
operate only if and when the united
nations wants them to i also like that
they don't know any other names for
vision so they're just like yeah just
sign the word vision i get you you don't
have a name now obviously that's not up
captain america's alley at the moment
considering the last time he trusted the
government to run things they turned out
to be hydra and here's my favorite thing
about this story for steve rogers here
if you take the captain america movies
as a trilogy it started with him being
basically the face of the military and
of the government he would even do those
uso tours and stuff but then in the
second movie he's struggling to deal
with being a soldier in the modern day
and having to deal with the current
government now in this movie we see the
end of that arc where he's completely
broken away from that government and
he's become the kind of rogue soldier
that at one point he would have helped
them hunt down though i don't think he's
become so punk that he's painted his
fingernails black and he's got a bunch
of rings on from like hot topic or
something this is probably a glimpse at
the hands of black widow or scarlet
witch or somebody i know how much bucky
means you
stay out of this one
please
you only make this worse
you saying you'll arrest me we see more
of bucky on the run and then cap looks
to be browsing incognito uh so we're
definitely much later in the movie here
which is why black widow doesn't know
where he is anymore and she's having to
let him know that she'll arrest him if
he keeps running this is a really
interesting contrast to the last time
cap had to go undercover because black
widow was actually hiding out with him
then and it's like why can't they go
back to the way they were then they were
making out and they were like playing
with laptops with that hipster guy at
the apple store
i have the exact same glasses wow you
two are practically twins yeah i wish
specimen oh also black widow's clearly
around some drama herself considering
the fire trucks and the u.n peacekeepers
behind her so it's probably after that
un explosion earlier and considering
she's asking cap not to come to bucky's
aid here stay out of this one
you only make this worse really sounds
like everybody thinks bucky was the one
that blew up the u.n meeting
there will
be consequences
captain you seem a little defensive well
it's been a long day then probably after
bucky and cap have been on the run for a
while we see a bunch of mass german
military types around them and it looks
like cap and bucky actually maybe
surrendered to them though it could be a
trick and then a totally different
moment we see the glowing eyes of the
billionaire playboy super genius who's
having to battle the all-american
superhero and just for a second it felt
like we were maybe watching a different
trailer
but no this is iron man we're saying and
two things to note here one damn that
looks like a really painful shiner how
much you want to bet that came from
steve at some point but two note how his
helmet appears to have retracted behind
his head that's totally new to the iron
man suit and while it's not the craziest
thing that tony is still updating the
suits there are rumors that we might see
the bleeding edge armor in this movie
and when it comes to iron man armor
that's one of the most badass versions
it's actually made up of like nano
technology that is kind of activated by
tony's mind it can retract into his skin
whatever it has tons of amazing upgrades
and there's a chance that something
about this armor could be really
important to the plot but we'll get back
to that
if we can accept limitations we're not
better than bad guys
that's not the way i see it
sometimes i want to punch you in your
perfect teeth then we see captain falcon
at maybe the new avengers facility uh
but cap's shield has been taken away and
if you look closely you'll see also
falcons wings it seems like maybe part
of the accords are that the avengers
have to give up their tech and only get
to use them when the u.n says so also if
you freeze frame just right you'll get a
glimpse at two other characters one is
whoever martin freeman is playing they
haven't confirmed that yet and the other
one is agent 13 sharon carter who last
we heard had left shield to join the cia
now how the cia is involved in all this
i have no idea but that's interesting
but what's even more interesting than
that is the fact that sharon carter is
there at all because she has such a
crazy impact on the civil war plot in
the comics and while it looks like they
are changing lots of stuff from the
comics her story might stay the same and
if it does this movie is probably not
gonna have a happy ending and don't look
that up if you don't like spoilers then
we get some shots of cap and bucky
prepping for battle maybe the final one
and tony telling captain that he wants
to punch him in his teeth and he doesn't
have the black eye then but it kind of
feels like maybe he's about to get it
i just want to make sure we consider all
our options
because people that shoot at you usually
wind up shooting at me too
then we get a great shot of falcon's new
duds and the wings look like they've
gotten a nice paint job but that design
in those colors is actually a reference
to the look of falcon's costume from the
comics then we see cap without his
shield getting fired at from a chopper
by this super serious dude with a super
serious gun and then it becomes clear
that falcon is also on the run or he
just really loves captain's due look and
really wants to be his best friend but
then holy crap falcon gets the best kick
in the trailer with this amazing
freaking flying spin kick thing so cool
you know what's about to happen
we then see black widow in her super
tactical zippery body suit thing and
considering that they're at an airport
now which we're going to see a lot of in
a moment what's about to happen is
probably a huge fight between a lot of
former friends which is always so sad up
next we see cap arriving at the ifid
which is the institute for infectious
diseases and taking a look at the logo
it definitely looks like that's africa
and you know what else is in africa
wakanda where black panther's from but
we will get to him in a second i'm also
going to point out that these two
different uniforms on these wiped out
soldiers could mean that this is the
same location we saw crossbones and crew
busting into earlier and the idea that
they're busting into an infectious
disease center is totally terrifying
because then that adds yet another
threat to this movie the bad guys
unleashing a deadly virus on people and
this is why everybody needs to start
getting along there is way too much
drama to deal with you want to punch
your way out of this
what do we do
we fight
wait here we are at the airport scene
that looks like it's going to be one of
the biggest sequences of the movie in it
we see tony standing with his bestie war
machine and he's definitely sporting
that black eye and this is also a really
good moment to take a look at that new
iron man suit that definitely has more
layers to it than previous versions and
now tony's team is supposed to be
representing the larger force here but
at least in this moment they definitely
look outnumbered with captain's own
version of the unofficial avengers that
are siding with him we've got hawkeye
scarlet witch falcon and bucky all
behind cap and rumor has it that there's
a chance right before this moment
ant-man was also running alongside them
and now he's just too small for us to
see and of course you could make that
argument for any moment in the trailer
but he might be there though you guys
know i don't think he's that black spot
that some of you pointed out i think
that's a piece of gum but anyway it's a
big team running at them and scarlet
witch now is definitely a flyer these
days it just doesn't feel like that side
is the underdogs anymore though i'm not
saying you should underestimate team
iron man because you can see war machine
is doing some crazy damage with his
rockets and he's sending hawkeye and
scarlet witch running and from what i
can tell also black panther's on their
team too he gets that like badass reveal
shot where the sun is peeking out just a
little bit like making it look that much
cooler but i actually prefer his next
shot more where he pulls that crazy
double leg drop kick on bucky oh and
that suit that he's wearing which also
looks really cool is covered in
vibranium which is that insanely strong
metal that cap's shield is made out of
it's actually a really rare metal but
the only place that has a crap ton of it
is the home of black panther wakanda
that could actually be where we're
seeing black widow a second later and
everything from here on out is complete
insanity you can tell because the opera
singers are now on full blast
now in the comics black panther actually
tries his best to stay neutral during
civil war but here it definitely seems
like he's after bucky like after kicking
him in the face a second ago he starts
chasing him down the street and the
russo's confirmed that black panther's
got a really personal reason why he's in
the movie so in the comics black panther
who's also known as t'challa his dad
tachaka was the leader of wakanda and he
got assassinated some long time ago but
it almost feels like maybe they could
have changed some things around to make
it so that black panther at least thinks
that it could have been our winter
soldier assassin friend who did it maybe
that's just guessing though and if
that's not bad enough in winter soldier
they kind of implied that bucky could
have been involved in tony's dad's death
too so yeah that guy's not catching any
breaks now in this next shot holy crap
steve is holding down a helicopter this
is by far the strongest we've seen
captain america be in the marvel movies
and i think this moment isn't just about
looking cool though it does there's a
reason that cap is using more strength
than he ever has here and it's got
something to do with what's inside that
helicopter and apparently even the actor
chris evans was doing most of this stunt
so here in this moment you can see he's
really struggling really straining and
my lord his arms look like they have
footballs in them like damn dude i'm
actually worried about you you're too
jacked and then check out this moment
here you can see bucky's actually trying
to pull iron man's arc reactor out of
his suit he's also mouthing something
and if i'm reading his lips correctly
it's a huge spoiler so i'm actually not
gonna say what i think he's saying but
feel free to figure it out at your own
risk i'm sorry tommy
you know i wouldn't do this if i had any
other choice
but he's my friend
so was i
captain runs through an exploding
hospital maybe the ifid again and then
in this next shot with rhodey totally
mangled it looks like we're still at the
airport probably the aftermath of that
battle but look at his chest his ark
reactor has been ripped out of his suit
did bucky do that and if so why it could
just be because it's a sure way to stop
someone wearing a stark suit but he was
going after tony's too it just seems
like it might be a little more than a
coincidence i don't know and if you're
wondering if war machine is dead here i
don't know i don't think so because
they're showing it in the trailer but it
is well known that someone is supposed
to die in this movie and there's
definitely more than one death in the
comics so i don't think anybody's
actually safe and finally the most
heartbreaking moment of this whole thing
sorry tommy you know i wouldn't do this
if i had any other choice but he's my
friend
so was i cap telling tony that he's only
doing this because bucky's his friend
and tony's like yeah we used to be
friends too look at both their faces
they're all mangled and bruised and it's
like damn guys couples counseling
something you got to fix this oh also do
you see in tony's heads up display you
can see what looks like his old arc
reactor design which might be another
clue that these arc reactors are really
important as the trailer wraps up we see
the brutal two-on-one fight where iron
man is taking on both history's
deadliest assassin and the world's
greatest soldier and in case that's not
a bad enough combo he's doing it in
close quarters combat which is both of
their strengths and not at all what he's
good at and this is one of the best
moments of the trailer not just because
of the amazing choreography that's going
on but the way cap and bucky are
exchanging cap's shield there's a time
in the comics when bucky takes on the
captain america persona and i feel like
they're really trying to imply that he's
totally capable of doing that now okay
so that may have been the trailer that
was insanely packed with action but
there was a ton of stuff they didn't
even touch on can i just remind everyone
that spider-man is in this movie too now
based on this trailer i'm starting to
think that his part and vision's part
are probably closer to cameo length than
full featured players but still we've
got the two of them ant-man who we
didn't see baron zemo there's just way
more stuff that's gonna be in this movie
it's no wonder why they kept hulk and
thor out of it there's no room those two
also might be able to kick everyone's
ass so another good reason to keep them
out but still huge movie okay my
questions for you all one this movie
really feels like two sets of buddies
against each other captain america and
bucky up against the two other buddies
iron man and roadie so what's going on
with falcon is he like hey aren't i your
best friend too cap like i feel like
something could happen there and there
are rumors about somebody on one team
switching to the other side could it be
falcon could it be scarlet witch could
it be black widow who do you think it's
gonna be who's gonna be the traitor two
what do you think baron zemo is gonna do
in this movie he's supposed to be the
main villain and we didn't even see him
so what do you think he's up to and
three what side are you on i'm straight
up torn because i would normally say cap
because it's cool that you know he's
like the little guy in this but watching
it he seems like a badass and his team
looks amazing and tony stark looks so
sad i'm just completely torn what do you
think let me know your answers to those
in the comments below and also feel free
to tweet your questions at me uh at fimo
and let me know any moments that maybe i
missed in the trailer we've got so many
great videos coming out and we're
working so freaking hard to get them out
but we happen to just be a two-man team
it's me and ted so thank you so much for
being patient if you want to know when
our new stuff is coming out just follow
at new rockstars we put updates there
for when you can expect a new video but
thanks so much for hanging in there guys
i've been phil molina thank you for
watching civil war is a real thing that
is really happening in a real movie and
that is so cool alright i will catch you
next time bye